for the tampa bay rays here this
afternoon they will be going with the
right-hander michael walka
making his 10th start of the season 15th
overall game the record one and two era
5.26
and a swing and a miss and he does get
him with that
change of pace well that's the pitch and
when he is able to
command the fastball early for strikes
the cutter
has a a short suddenness to it
it makes that pitch so much
little better ball and that's grabbed by
bruhan
and the throw to first he got him
outstanding play
first opportunity for the rookie in his
major league career
and he is up to it great play right
there
welcome to the show young man ranging to
his left that ball
almost by him and now you've got to
recover and finish it off with the throw
a little help from g-man choi
what a heck of a play there by vidal
brujan
and a high shot back into center field
for kiermeier
he is there waiting and puts it away a
one two three inning
well j.c mejia will be making his
seventh start and his last start against
houston he
scuffled he went three innings first
ball swinging in a ground ball to
ahmed rosario with the shift on retires
brandon lau
tops it to second cesar goes to second
base for the force on joy
two down this one got him on the
foot meadows is hit by a pitch here
so the reigns will have two men on but
al bruhan will make his
major league debut has a hitter now
and there's a line shot face it into
right
wendell heads to the plate and the raves
break out in front
of the first major league hit by vidal
braun
on a one-two pitch a solid line drive an
rvi
single and the rays grab the lead
and they'll grab that baseball for
brujah you can tell he'll be fun to
watch play
and here is kevin kiermeier and that's a
base hit up the right field eye
extra beats is for kirbyr both men will
score
kirmeyer in its second with a double and
the rays grab a three-nothing lead
and the rays having a nice first inning
here off some questionable pitch
selections here from mejia you get to
the two outs it's tough getting that
third out
can ramirez get to it no but the other
ramirez can
and the inning is finally over lead off
the
second inning high drive
deep right field phillips back he's
looking up it's gone
nafrenimal strikes early here in his
first at bet
home run number 13 on the air second of
the series and the indians get a little
momentum
right back you know he said something
the other day
that these guys were just staying away
with him
he was going to take all the breaking
pitches away and just look for the
fastball and it looks like he did it
again
joey reached out to fielder's choice in
the first inning
liner up the right side that's going to
be fair
pounding into the corner extra bases for
wendell
a stand-up double with one out of the
third
two men on with one out for fidel gruhan
a little chopper ramirez with the throw
to first
to get brouhan and the runners advance
to second and third
now kevin keermeyer with two men in
scoring position
three two and it's lifted deep into
right
johnson will go back and that one is
gone
3-2 pitch and caremeyer hits it out
a three-run blast for the rave center
fielder
that will make it a 6-1 game
tiermeyer has driven in five of the six
runs
yeah and with two strikes not letting
that fastball get by him the mistake by
mejia when he has left that two seamer
up in the zone
it flattens out and ray's hitters have
not missed it there it is
and there it goes to the bottom of the
fourth
that's a shot oh my out of here
in a hurry near the back wall and
another home run for brandon lau
he's got a nice stretch going here
that's 18 on the year
six home runs in his last 13 games if
you're gonna challenge lau with the
fastball out over the plate it had
better be up near the letters
at the belt you are asking for trouble
exhibit a
and the range now leads seven to one
well
you want to be careful your seven and
eight hitters are aboard they're at
second and third now
so wacom records the first out of the
inning striking out daniel johnson
pops it up this time wendell's after it
into foul territory to make the catch
two gone ground ball shortstop
walls makes the play and cleveland will
leave
two men in scoring possession here's
brett phillips 0 for two
high shot off the bat of brett phillips
well tagged got a chance god
home run for phillips fourth home run of
the year for brett phillips
and the rays pack on another run it's
eight to one
it hit the netting above the raised tank
brett phillips with his fourth home run
of the season
ties his career high in home runs
already has career highs and stolen
bases and runs bad at him
tell you what this ball was crushed i
mean you could see the lifted the swing
right into that baseball on time and
going after the race goodness for the
netting
bryant sheriff the new pitcher the
left-hander takes over
from michael walka very good job by
walker today
and this one sweeps in there for a
strike
zimmer caught looking one away in the
seventh inning
and there's a wave and a miss perez
out number two strikeout number two
the high chop back off the mound sheriff
with the quick toss to first
save the call well for the
time being it's going to be a base hit
the rays
i think they got him and they're going
to take a look at it
well and difficult play here
for sheriff that ball you know kind of
over his head so he's got to retreat
make the catch
and then make the throw
oh not even close he's out
johnson will be out
no sooner did the earpiece go on that it
came off the headset
and this game is over the rays have
taken game one
of the series it's an 8-1 final